nicht mehr wegzudenken
die freiheit die unser fahrrad bietet
einfach los radl und die gegend genießen
schnell von a nach b kommen
all das haben wir karl freiherr von
drais zu verdanken er hat 1817 das
urfahraner erfunden
genau genommen war es eine laufmaschine
das technoseum in mannheim zeigt die
geschichte des fahrrads denn in mannheim
hat karl von drais seine erste fahrt
unternommen
schon damals war vieles an dem gefährt
so wie wir es heute kennen nur die
pedalen treten die laufmaschine des ur
fahrrad der freiherr von drais hatte
schon zwei gleich große räder eine
lenkung und auch eine bremse war schon
vorgesehen dass vieles drin was das neue
fahrrad das moderne fahrrad ausmacht
trotz der geniale idee ging das produkt
noch nicht gleich durch die decke
die anschaffungskosten von 40 gulden
überstiegen das jahresgehalt vieler
menschen er 50 jahre später wurde das
rad weiter entwickelt beim tretkurbel
reduziert wurde das vorderrad nun mit
zwei pedalen angetrieben 1867 wurde es
auf der pariser weltausstellung
vorgestellt es ging in serie hatte aber
noch tun
mit der tretkurbel im vorderrad war vor
allen dingen unglaublich schwer mit
einem schmiedeeisernen rahmen
aber und das war das neue man muss die
füße vom boden nehmen das heißt dass auf
vielen war noch ein wesentlich
komplizierter als es bei der
laufmaschine war noch schneller
voranzukommen wurde das vorderrad immer
größer und höher bis zu anderthalb meter
nun kam man zwar schnell vorwärts
aber es kam auch zu gefährlichen schluss
daher steht das modell hier im museum
auf einem ständer gut dass länder steht
mehr sicherheit gab es ab den frühen
1800 80er jahren mit dem sicherheits
niederrad mit zwei gleich großen rädern
nun krieg eine kette das hinterrad an
so ist es bis heute um die
jahrhundertwende wurde das fahrrad zum
verkehrsmittel für alle war es anfangs
noch spielzeug des tages machte es dann
die arbeiterschaft mobil und auch frauen
stiegen aufs rad
die ersten frauen die fahrrad gefahren
sind in den 98 jahren waren extrem
mutige frauen es bedeutete ja auch dass
man seine kleidung ändern mussten mit
einem bodenlangen rock schwer möglich er
verschaffte ihnen die gleichen
freiheiten die sie auf den männern
verschärft hat man war unabhängig konnte
größere strecken fahren konnte ausflügen
machen und entkam ein bisschen auch der
kontrolle durch familie ehemann
wer immer der kontrollierte
juni für licht am fahrrad sorgte zum
beispiel die kapitel am kap ist ein
gemisch aus calcium- und kohle tropft
wasser drauf entsteht ein gas das trend
wichtig war nur dass einem das wasser
nicht ausgeht
eine möglichkeiten wäre gewesen hinein
zu spucken was nicht so effektiv weil
die menge einfach zu gering ist und was
die meisten leute einfach gemacht haben
die haben da er ruiniert
vor fast 100 jahren hat man auch schon
räder mit hilfsmotoren ausprobiert die
vorläufer des elektrobikes doch trotz
aller technischer raffinesse er liebte
das fahrrad ab dem 1950 eine erneute
durststrecke durch den boom von autos
und motorrädern derart markt versuchte
mit klapprädern fürs auto zu punkten
oder mit wundern zerreden
und siehe da heute ist der fahrrad
populärer denn je wenn sie jemand 895
eingefroren und die würden würden denn
heute wieder auftauen dann würde er ganz
viel nicht erkennen das fahrrad werden
häufig mountainbikes für die räder und e
bikes sind nicht mehr aus unserem alltag
wegzudenken und außerdem ist
fahrradfahren gut für die gesundheit und
die umwelt
[Musik]